first up he is the senior fellow at the
Brookings institution and author of the
book of boys and men why the modern male
is struggling why it matters and what to
do about it Richard Reeves
Richard
wow yeah
it looked like a model of the modern
male thank you too oh I appreciate that
so I the first thing I want to ask you
about this book I'm reading about it and
then about it the book itself then about
it is that just broaching this subject
which is really non-controversial in the
sense that it is really happening the
modern male really is in trouble we have
statistics and data but just covering
this is somehow dangerous for the author
could you explain that yeah that was the
fear that was what people said to me
before writing it is if if you just
write about boys and men people will
assume that you're Josh Hawley
effectively that you're just part of the
mana's fear you're on the alt right and
the more people said that the more I
thought I really do need to write this
book because I think it's an axiom of
political life and cultural life that if
responsible people don't address real
problems in a straightforward way
irresponsible people are going to
exploit them yeah I think that's just a
a lesson of history and so I
I lead with the facts let's get to some
solutions and also let's let's let's do
ourselves the uh the favor of assuming
we can think two thoughts at once that
we can think there are problems for boys
and men especially working class boys
and men and black boys and men there are
still many issues still facing women and
girls and guess what we can hold both
those thoughts in our head at the same
time of course
but I must say just anecdotally as
someone who you know never been married
never have children but the P you know
I've certainly know most of my friends
did that and and their kids are have
grown up and I've seen that and I've
heard over the years especially when
they got a little older a lot of times I
hear you know I worry about my boy the
girl's doing fine but the boy I can't
get him off PornHub and the grades are
bad and
I've heard that a lot yeah what changed
what I mean when I went to college it
was unfortunately almost all men
certainly where I went right where did
you go Cornell okay it sucked
I believe you yeah and uh you know
now it's flipped now the college is a
majority women yeah in fact 50 years ago
there was there was a gender gap of
about 13 points in favor of men now
there's a gap of 15 points in favor of
women so there's more gender inequality
on college campuses today than there was
in 1972. it's just flipped it's the
other way around what's the short answer
for why this happened I think the
education system actually suits girls
and women better than boys and men on
average and we didn't know that because
previously we weren't encouraging girls
and women to go on to college so under
conditions of sexism actually their
natural advantages in the classroom
didn't really show up but since we've
taken the lid off women's educational
opportunities and aspirations they just
blown right past the boys in high school
and college Etc and so it turned you
know it turns out that a Level Playing
Field exposes who are the better players
and in our current education system that
rewards sitting still turning your
homework in paying attention looking to
the Future etc those are all good on
average girls just have in Greater
abundance than boys that's a that's a
fact I'm sure I'm sure it is but I must
also say I've heard this forever now not
forever but for many years that your
boys are at a disadvantage because they
have a harder time sitting still I'm
sure I did too but when I went to school
they didn't give a [ __ ] it's like sit
still and we did you know you're a boy
so what yes you're a little more antsy
but you still can be told to pay
attention and told to study and do all
the things we were told to do isn't it
more that parents are just too indulgent
no I I am
it may well be disaster in the classroom
I have to tell you my experience is
similar to yours is that most of the
parents I know are not really indulging
their boys they're worrying like hell
about their boys and trying to help them
out in various ways and increasingly I
think parents are coming to realize that
the current way that classrooms are run
and the current structure of Education
just isn't suiting our boys very well so
currently almost one in four boys in in
the US have been diagnosed with a
developmental disability almost one in
four I suggest that might be less about
the boys and more about the system that
we're trying to force them through which
it turns out doesn't suit all of them
very well and so rather than blaming
boys I think we should be reforming
education systems so that it's as male
friendly as it is female friendly
well how do you do that well I mean how
well one thing one thing we could do is
reverse the tide which has seen male
teachers basically leaving the classroom
so it's only 24 of K-12 teachers now are
men was down it was 33 in the 1980s
almost no early years educators are men
and so the teaching profession has
become steadily more and more female
we've also retreated almost entirely
from vocational education technical high
schools apprenticeships Etc which on
average suit boys and men better but
we've retreated from all of that and so
let's bring some of those back technical
high schools more male teachers more
recess and by the way if it's true that
boys find it hard to sit still
sure you could tell them to sit still
but might also be a good good idea every
now and again to run them around let's
have more phys ed more extracurricular
activity and so on but other than saying
there's something wrong with them right
no I agree both right at some point you
just have to sit still and pay attention
and by the way for me maybe we should
have more male teachers but when I was
in sixth grade the only reason I paid
attention was Mrs Hill
[Music]
if you saw those sweaters she wore you
would understand
but she sounds pretty scary no she was
not scary no no she was sexy
I'm sorry
Mrs Hill was not scary which which grade
was this this is sixth grade you know
the beginning of bonerville
it comes at different ages for different
boys right not an area of expertise for
me but sixth grade's quite early Bill
thank you
[Applause]
I'm blushing